i know right it's it's crazy but i want
to bring in uh ben hernandez ben
benjamin how are you
doing well yo oh great great great it's
great to have you um
benjamin you actually were
in a restaurant um with ted cruz and
asking him about some of these questions
that jim acosta was actually asking um
the judge in our nra board member here
what what was your what was your main
question did you did you have a set of
questions that you wanted to ask ted
cruz i mean
what what what message were you trying
to send
i mean i think the message that i was
trying to send is very simply can we do
the most basic things
around gun control and i think to me you
know his answers or lack of answers
tells me a lot right i have a lot of i
have a lot of thoughts on guns and what
we could do and everything that we need
to do i didn't start there i said okay
let's start with background checks can
we start with there that because it has
the support of the majority of the
american public can we do that and to
not hear
an answer
on that you know blaming the democrats
and this and that i'm like man i'm not
talking about the democrats i'm talking
about you you're my elected official
right so so that's what i was trying to
get across is like can we do something
basic on this if you don't want to do
something you know you don't want to do
everything that i think we should do is
can we start where there's common ground
on this
so tell us a little bit about your
background because this isn't the first
time that you've thought that you woke
up and thought about
um the issue of gun safety and the issue
of
maybe common sense
reform if you will this isn't the first
time you thought it so tell us about
your background tell us how you've come
to
to even
confront ted cruz to ask him these
questions your elected official ask him
for the answers to your questions
you know i feel this has been
certainly was a couple of days in the
making you know i was there at the
protest outside the george r brown
convention center with indivisible
houston you know uh my buddy daniel
cohen we we went uh the day on thursday
we went and we put a cut out of ted cruz
in front of the nra's doors you know
it's that we wrote on his chest you know
i murdered teachers and children because
his inaction effectively is doing this
right and we put it in front of the
doors and so you know that i was in that
mode for a couple of days but also like
you know i since
2018
after santa fe
this blue wristband i've been wearing it
i got it at a march for our lives event
here in houston i've been wearing that
wristband every single day since 2018 as
a reminder to myself
right that we have not done anything
meaningful on gun violence in this
country and so for me it's just been
years of of building up and saying we
haven't done anything we need to do
something
and that's
kind of what you said in um 2m at the
restaurant i actually had the clip here
uh let's uh pull that up and now this
video is shot is it by someone who is
who is with you is that is it what i
understand yeah so my wife and i were
having dinner at dubsan sushi we were
wrapping up the dinner when uh i turn
over and i look and like ted cruz is
walking and i'm like you gotta be
kidding me right like
you're not just gonna go and after
you've already speak at the end of the
convention like nothing and then go out
for for for
for dinner you know like and come into
the space where i am at
and not hear from me right right um and
so that's that was a thought so she was
the one who who captured the whole
interaction on video well it's about two
minutes and 20 seconds is the video here
on the internet and i believe it goes
from where you are
taking a selfie with ted cruz um to the
end to where they're actually escorting
you out of the restaurant
um so let's let's watch a bit of this
and then i'll let you comment and tell
us more about this interaction because
um the video that first went viral we
showed earlier it was kind of from a
bystander and they caught the very end
they didn't get this part so i want to
make sure we show this
okay you ready
okay hold on
all right one
two three
go
we're good
yeah we got it
is
um yeah
he he actually says the words to you
you're not listening to me and i don't
think your intent was
was to hear him out i think you know his
intentions you know what his opinions
are on these things i don't think it's a
secret that ted cruz takes money from
the nra and is going to stand with the
nra because they they fill his coffers
with money
he wasn't listening to you um and i
think that's probably
why texans should see this moment this
moment in the clip not the moment where
you know you got very passionate at the
very end and they they took you out to
get it to get you away from him because
he didn't want to speak to you anymore
but i think
the main issue here is that ted cruz
is not listening he's not hearing and i
don't believe it's just ted cruz i think
it's greg abbott i think it's dan
patrick i don't think it's just the
politicians that you have elected in the
state of texas i think there's
politicians all over this country who
are not listening they're only telling
us what we're supposed to do not
actually listening to what we want to
have done like that's the whole point of
a democratic constitutional republic
give us your thoughts on that yeah
absolutely i mean i that's the tragedy
here right you know in the face of
something like uvalde where you should
be listening to people and listening to
what we could do to prevent uh you know
another
mass shooting where elementary children
died you know you're not even willing to
listen you're trying to give me the same
canned response that you gave earlier in
the week you know that was like what was
so offensive to me is like talking about
the democrat like i don't care about the
democrats man you're ted cruz like i
want to know what you will do and if you
can get behind something like this
you're not let you know at some point
later i think he calls me ignorant like
like you just met me i've been watching
you for a minute i've been listening to
you as my representative for a very long
minute and you're gonna call me ignorant
based on this interaction i wasn't
offended that he called me anywhere but
it tells you a lot about how he thinks
of people and his constituents right
instead of saying like okay let me
listen to you what what what should we
do benjamin right and i'm here to listen
right right but you you want to throw
these canned responses and deflect
responsibility i wasn't having it you
know and i'm not going to let you go and
give me your spiel and do the same thing
you've done over and over because you
came into the space where i was having
dinner right and you thought that was a
safe space i don't know why but here's
what's interesting he directs me to his
nra speech you know to go ahead and
watch that you know in his speech he
complains about the elites who live in
gated communities and have private
security you know you know who kicked me
out of that restaurant his private
security
there could be no place closer to the
gated upscale communities of houston
than we were dining that night and so
i'm like really
that's that's your response when you're
the one who's actually doing these
things gaslighting the rest of us well
yeah i think i think you completely hit
it on the head right there like the gas
lighting i mean we've seen it again and
again right it is like you know when he
gave the interview with sky news he said
i'm sorry you feel that way right i'm
sorry you don't like american
exceptionalism or whatever you say right
like it's that dismissive quality of
politicians especially republicans who
say i'm here to listen i'm here to care
you know i'm here for you and then
immediately
we'll say
you know
you you think what you think and you
feel how you feel but i'm really not
going to change the opinion i have or at
least i'm not going to change opinion
based on the nra payroll that i'm on but
i think the other thing too is like yeah
you know he says go and watch this
speech that i gave today at the nra you
go back and watch his speech or
or trump's speech and you see in there
that they keep hitting the same thing
which is
one single point of entry we need high
security we need guards we need teachers
armed we need uh to really go after the
mentally ill and lock them up in mental
institutions and then the other one is
also how you know we need to
um
we need to not ban guns and it's the
democratic policies that would actually
cause more or if anything the policies
that they're introducing or or have
suggested would actually do nothing
you know they're the we're the party the
democrats are the party that uh have not
contributed anything to the conversation
when in fact if you look at there are
literal receipts things are introduced
into the floor and said hey let's vote
on this and they say
no we're not going to but you know
that's that's a good point gabe because
there was a time in our history and i
think people it and it was recent
history where the democratic party had
an arm of their party that they really
did take a lot of money from the nra
they did they did stop any kind of
common sense
gun laws
the the shift
in the political spectrum though
is that most people have common sense
thoughts around firearms like it's not
uncommon for someone who is even an nra
member themselves to have common sense
thoughts
around gun safety and what we should and
should not do in this country when it
comes to
guns especially
these assault style guns
the the shift is and i think this is
where they're losing their narrative
when they're talking about banning back
doors the shift in the politics is that
there's only one party that actually has
the backbone to stand against a handful
of families in this country who
manufacture these weapons because that's
really what we're up against here we are
up against a handful of families very
wealthy families who have inherited
these manufacturers in this country that
absolutely do not care what happens to
other people in this country as long as
they get to get their profits from the
technology that they have been able to
develop throughout the decades and they
want to put it on our streets for pure
blooded profit excuse the pun but that
is truly what is happening is we we have
got ourselves in a situation where only
one political party is willing to
protect those handful of families to
put their technology that their
companies that they inherited that they
own
on the streets no matter what the
consequence and that is really where
we're at in the political game here and
that is why i believe that people like
ted cruz won't listen because if they do
start listening they're going to realize
that the money that they take is blood
money it is the blood is on their hands
and they're they're definitely not
um strong enough they're cowards
to admit that and he doesn't admit it in
this video i wanna i wanna finish it up
here because he really does get cowardly
here when you really start to uh talk
about things well i think as soon as he
looks over and realizes your wife is
recording still that's what like there's
that look of like
uh okay we gotta we gotta deal with this
situation right now
so let's finish here um and then i'll
let you tell us about what happened
after the video because that's what i'm
really interested in because we don't
see the the after what what what ensued
after if there was anything
so if you look at the law
do you know this shooter waited waited
until
know that no you know that but you stand
here you stand at that you stand at the
nra convention it is harder it is harder
when there are more guns to stop gun
violence
it is not
is
[Music]
when 19 children died 19 children died
as on your hands that is on your hands
right through that wondering
so benjamin
i want to tell you that i think you
speak for a lot of americans um in this
video
um when especially at the end when
you're saying that it's on his hands
because he said things and um to you
that like oh the democrats are
filibustering um it's the democrats
democrats democrats when he is still
would be public
right
his party has a lot of control so much
control over the state of texas and the
gun laws in the state of texas
that greg abbott cheered
cheered when they passed a law and and
was was was actually upset that that
california had more gun sales than texas
um
and i think you speak for most people
out there most parents especially when
they see the tragedy that it's not just
happened in uvalde um sandy hook uh
el paso
marjory stoneman douglas in parkland
florida i mean the list goes on and on
and on here that that at some point at
some point something has to be done but
what i what i want to know here is
we kind of get the end of the video um
and i don't know if it's because twitter
will only let a 2 minute and 20 second
video be posted uh or if this video
continued what what actually happened
once you left the restaurant um can you
tell us a little bit about that was did
ted cruz reach out to you at all has he
said look i want to have a conversation
i want to have a reasonable discussion
with you i mean has he reached out at
all his team reached out at all do you
no no i mean his his uh
private security was the one who kicked
me out of the restaurant uh a lot of
people think it was a restaurant it
wasn't it was just two people from his
security and and uh
you know somebody sitting at his table
um but no one like you know when we get
there to the door i'm like no i'm
leaving man because that one of the
securities like you want to get arrested
i'm like i'm leaving man i'm leaving
right you know
what like what i mean like what on what
because you talk to him
i mean that's that's what they do right
my goal is like
you know what was more important to me
was to make sure that
i let ted cruz know that he's
responsible for his inaction right and
so once i said that and and they got me
to the door i was going to leave anyways
right right no interest in sharing a
space with ted cruz beyond every you
know second that i have to
um and so yeah we left and then i looked
down at my shoe and i was like what why
am i wearing flip-flops turns out i
ripped my shoe in the process the sole
of my shoe because i was pushing so hard
to stand my ground and hold my place
while they're yanking me
that i ended up ripping my shoes so that
that could tell you like i don't know
that the video captures that but a lot
of force was going into that and then
you saw the moment when i turned on like
who's holding me man like i'm trying to
i'm just trying to have just trying to
talk to him yeah we're trying to talk to
him you guys are you guys are the
aggressors here ted cruz is the one who
is play you know and that and the same
thing happened in the sky news interview
where like you got like you guys are you
know arm and arm taking the photo or
like the photo yeah but just like in the
sky news like he's the one who is going
to take more advance on putting his
hands on you to be like look
that's that's nice and all but i'm not
going to really care for it and like
they're the aggressors they're the ones
who are now con you know
you know checking you they're the ones
that are pulling you back
right so i don't know if there's some
sort of case for you here but like that
is something too it's like they're the
ones that technically kind of
made the physical touch they made the
assault on you so
yeah i don't know
well i i appreciate you um standing your
ground and really making your voice be
heard let me ask you if ted cruz's
office did reach out if they did reach
out and want to have a conversation with
him i don't think you you wouldn't be
afraid to have a conversation with ted
cruz in private or in public would you
private or in public better for me in
public because more people need to hear
the answers right i was asking questions
that that people people
want answers to so i'd love that
opportunity
because
it was unresolved you didn't give me an
answer right i asked about a simple
thing i have a lot of thoughts about you
know what we should do about gun
regulations in this country but i wasn't
going to all of my thoughts i was going
to the simple thing where i know a
majority of americans are behind and so
yeah let's have that conversation and
let's make it public why not well what
are you afraid of right um so i'd love
that opportunity yeah because you say
what are you afraid of but of course for
him he's like i'm afraid of everything
right well i mean obviously in the in
the confrontation that was caught on uh
several different cameras in
in the restaurant there um that he was
very uncomfortable with not not only
just hearing the things that you had to
say but having to
to formulate answers that was other than
his
you know his go-to's democrats fault um
you know
more guns
is the answer you know this
because they continue on this
this this idea and they they're really
losing ground on some of their arguments
like they're back to the reason why we
have to have ar-15s as wild hogs like
literally that is where they're back to
in some of these arguments matt gatz was
tweeting it the other day that the
reason why our constitutional right
affords us to have ar-15s is because we
have we have feral hogs in certain parts
of the country like we've had barrel
hogs in this country for hundreds of
years and we didn't have ar-15 style
right i also wasn't aware that we had
that many hog hunters out there right
like well
and here's the thing i i actually am not
against someone who wants to
uh hunt wild game to have the kind of
weapons that they need to have i just
believe that someone should actually be
responsible and held accountable for
those weapons to hunt with those weapons
for wild game i mean if you really need
a rifle that has a high capacity
magazine um to shoot wild game i come
from a rural area i went deer hunting as
a kid i we didn't we we took deer rifles
that held six shots and really honestly
that was that was triple doing it i mean
if you had to shoot twice
um at a whitetail deer because whitetail
deer are not heavily armed they don't
wear body armor i mean this is wild game
and if you need more than two maybe
three shots
you probably need to pick a different
recreation or just
just go to the shoot yes head back to
the shooting range and just saying maybe
there for a little bit but but that
their arguments are falling apart here
with the back door talk um how do you
feel when they when they do this thing
where they try to distract from every
because you said you went to several
march of uh of our lives and i think um
david hogg actually announced was it
yesterday i believe that they're going
to go to dc yeah on june 11th uh which
um
i've already suggested they gave that we
live stream that um that rally or parts
of that rally but depending on the time
of day and the stuff how long it is but
we want to try to live stream that to
get that out to everybody but how do you
feel about some of this dodginess of the
of the actual issue when they talk about
backdoors and
hardening our schools as if our children
should go to prisons to be educated i
mean i think that that's why i say like
you know like ted cruz just has to be
the unluckiest guy because like you know
i wasn't having any of that right like i
think that's why people i've heard
people like wow you interrupted him you
don't talk yeah damn right because when
he was trying to give me those canned
answers i wasn't having i was like stop
like i'm not interested in that let's go
to background checks that's what i'm
asking you about give me an answer on
that give me an answer on that give me
and so i wasn't trying to let him escape
because you know i've seen what they do
and i don't i don't have any patience
for that right like i don't like i don't
have patience that i don't want your
canned answer i'm asking you a very
simple question why can't you get behind
something that the majority of americans
can get behind right and you don't have
an answer i don't have patience for your
garbage answers and they are garbage
answers because in the face of tragedy
that's all you can come up with right i
don't have time well and he's he's
here's the thing he's probably not also
the one that's coming up with the
answers right he's going to the nra or
the nra is coming to him and the
spokesperson says listen you're going to
have to run through these three bullet
points don't ever mention these things
but definitely keep reiterating these
things we want to distract away because
it's not the guns it's the back door or
it's the teacher or it's you know the
fact that we you know we don't have high
walls or
you know barbed wire fencing right
that's the problem it's not the fact
that we have more guns than people in
this country and then getting one is
probably more you know it's easier than
buying a pack of cigarettes or buying a
lotto ticket yeah
benjamin i appreciate you being in this
fight as many parents in this country do
um and i hope you continue to stay and
you continue to stay vocal and i
actually hope i i i actually am hoping
that you get a chance to talk to ted
cruz um one on one in a situation where
you can get some of the answers to your
questions he is your representative i
feel like he owes you um the time just
five ten minutes to sit down with you
and answer some of the questions that he
was
clearly unable to answer in the
restaurant there benjamin tell us where
where our viewers can find you where
they can follow you because i know
you're you're going to stay in this
fight
and it's vitally important that everyone
stick together
to make sure that that this country's
safe
yeah definitely follow me on twitter at
you see the handle there the benjamin
hdz um you know another thing that i
want to talk about is yeah the last
couple of days here a lot of people have
asked me you know like i said they say
you're here i'm like man i'm just doing
what i needed to do
but a question has come you know the
natural question is like how can
we do this with our elected officials
and i think like with the indivisible
houston group you know uh i think one
thing that we're gonna do two nights
from now on thursday we're in a live
stream um sort of uh a a a conversation
when one we're gonna take people through
the you know how we got to it about
answer the question everybody one wants
to know it was this stage right i'm like
no like y'all like answer that question
so take people through the video behind
the scenes but then also
leave them with
if you want to how can you do this with
your elected officials and create that
playbook to challenge them because the
reality is when they're hiding like ted
cruz behind private security and in his
gated community even though that's what
he accuses other people of you know when
they're hiding when you find them in the
street challenge them and this is how
you should challenge them because
there's a way to do that right um you
know and so we're going gonna take
people through a playbook um you know
and give people and empower people
really to do this with their elected
officials and this is not a partisan
thing hell whether it's a republican
democrat independent libertarian
whatever it is if your elected official
isn't creating this space for
constituents to ask questions and they
answer you go out and you make that
space if you see them on the street in
the grocery store at the theater or in a
restaurant you create that space because
they're actively hiding from us when
they represent us
well thank you guys
yeah tell us tell us where that's going
to be
yeah we're going to stream it we uh have
a the details in a couple of hours but
we're going to stream it on facebook
live um and also on youtube but you'll
you'll see details right there from my
handle coming out in a couple of hours
okay and then also some invisible
houston handle um you know because we we
a lot of people are asking like yeah we
need to do this how do we especially
after watching beto o'rourke do it as
well right confronting greg but i think
there's there's there's a movement
that's starting that people say wait a
minute i don't have to be
passive in this conference this is a
conversation and i need to make space
for myself and we need to make them have
this conversation i agree with you so so
when you when you tweet that out
everyone go follow ben uh at the
benjamin hdz on twitter the handles
there on the screen and we'll put it in
the the chat as well here um so so go
follow benjamin on twitter and benjamin
if you can send that to me or gabe and
we'll try to retweet it out to see if we
can get that out to as many people as as
we possibly can and get the audience to
help us circulate that around so that
way anyone who wants to watch um that
live stream can do that thank you for
joining us i really
and and come back please come back and
give us an update uh we want to talk to
you more about this issue it's not going
away and right now right
even even if there is some common sense
uh reform passed we still cannot take
our eye off the ball because uh these
these folks that are
that are out for the blood money of the
nra are not going to stop um it's
obvious that they're willing to do
almost anything give you any kind of
excuse they can't even blame a back door
for the events that happen
in uvalde uh the tragedy of the 19 dead
children and two dead teachers it's um
it's a shame that we have to do that so
thank you benjamin for joining us
everyone go check out um benjamin on
twitter to make sure you catch that live
stream uh i i'm i'm interested and i
think we might take a look at that so
we'll have you back soon benjamin i
appreciate it everyone stick around
we'll be right back thanks so much for
this break have a good one benjamin
thank you